North Korea is located in Northeast Asia.
It is a socialist system.
It was established on a Soviet model.
The economy is centrally controlled.
That system worked well in the early 60s but it ran into roadblocks, in part because of North Korea's isolation.
China is a kind of lifeline for goods, energy, and food to
North Korea, and North Korea is reported
to have as much as one quarter of its GDP
devoted to the military.
North Korea is estimated to have enough material
to build 10 to 16 nuclear weapons in 2016.
They've also been trying to develop a nuclear bomb
small enough that it could fit onto a missile--
in other words they're trying to expand their ability
to deliver a nuclear weapon
to a neighboring country, or, in the long term,
possibly even to the United States.
The U.S.-North Korea relationship may be
the most enduring hostile relationship
the United States has had with any country in the world.
Arguably the origins of the nuclear program in
North Korea go back to the 1960s.
It didn't really become of concern on the part of the U.S. until the late 1980s, at which time
a nuclear reactor was detected by satellites.
The U.S. began to focus on what could be done
in order to stop North Korea
from pursuing further nuclear development.
One method has been to
negotiate with North Korea.
Subsequently, the United States has used sanctions
following North Korea's nuclear tests.
Another important priority of U.S. policy toward
North Korea has been deterrence.
The main concern that the United States
has related to North Korea is in maintaining
the stability of South Korea and
preventing a war on the Korean Peninsula
that could evolve into a regional conflict.
Since the end of the Korean War,
the United States has maintained troops
in South Korea, and the U.S. interest in the
peninsula is directly related to its
security commitments to South Korea. In addition
the U.S. has an alliance with Japan.
Another U.S. interest is the fact that
the North Korean regime is probably
the worst human rights violator in the world.
China is the country that North Korea
is most dependent on, but its views
about the desired end state on the Korean Peninsula are different from those of the United States
and South Korea.
One policy option for the United States
in confronting the challenge posed by
North Korea's nuclear development might be
to manage the problem.
The U.S. could try to slow down
the North Korean nuclear program through
isolation, through sanctions. The U.S. could
continue to pursue deterrence, and they
can try to put pressure on North Korea
to get the North Koreans to move
in a different direction.
A second policy option would be to
go back to the negotiating table.
Another policy option might be
a preventive strike against
North Korea's nuclear program.
There's really no direct means that
the United States and North Korea have
to address their differences that does not
ultimately involve North Korea's neighbors
and American allies.